10 et voilà je ne suis pas heureuse je
suis malheureuse mon mari a peur de moi
je
ça va pas mais je m'en fous je vois là
je l'aimais je reste quoi qu'il arrive
je l'aimé je reste d'accord donc je
pense que de leur part ils simple ce
couple qui avait été très heureux et est
devenu une prison voilà et ni l'un ni
l'autre n'avait le courage de s'échapper
de cette prison des deux côtés
malheureuse pour autant à l'envisager de
faire un enfant avec sa table voilà
c'est ça alors aujourd'hui un autre
volet de la faire c'est jouer puisque la
famille de la victime de rang des plus
de 750 mille euros pour préjudice
d'affection ce que vous pouvez expliquer
à nos téléspectateurs
alors effectivement les parents d'aller
kia ainsi que la soeur et le beau frère
dan et ja ont formulé différentes
demandes qui le préjudice d'affection
qui est la souffrance endurée suite à la
perte d'alexia et c'est vrai que les
sommes qui ont été sollicités n'osant je
peux le dire littéralement surpris
750000 euros ils ont demandé s'est
jamais vu avant vraiment pratique
régulièrement la matière criminelle on
n'avait jamais vu de la des barèmes
exactement qui sont comment rouler
habituellement fixée c'est à dire que
voilà on sait combien une vigueur
combien on a des mystères vivront n'y a
pas de montant qu'un demi d'une vie vous
laisser le prix de l'achat 30 si vous
voulez et un parent qui perd un enfant
habituellement ses trente quarante mille
euros si vous voulez là on était à cent
cinquante mille euros par part en donc
on était vraiment dans des danses est
sûre je compte me louer un parent si on
prend par exemple madame fouillole voilà
trente quarante mille euros c'est plus
de moi les sommes qui sont alloués on
est à cent cinquante mille euros pour
madame fouilles
oui j'ai lu mais excusez moi il y avait
quand même dans cet argent parce que
c'est traduire en argent la douleur la
tristesse le poids du mensonge au site
quoi médiatique aussi le lobby
médiatique tout ce qu'ils ont de gros
dur à sac la somme est aussi bas oui et
quand c'est que l affaire était
tellement médiatisé on a tellement vu
les
les parents d'aller d'alexia que
forcément ça a joué et c'est pour ça que
la somme est très importante parce que
vous avez dit vous les avez tellement vu
mais finalement ils ont participé au
fait qu'on allait voir aussi oui après
après sur la marche sur la mangue et il
était là il était là c'était s'était
filmé donc il était là mais après ils
ont fait juste ils sont finis interview
sur bfm
mais c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
ce qui a joué aussi non non mais qui
demande énormément de l'argent non
monsieur nous vous avez passé tout à
l'heure un extrait de 2,2 2,5 4 épisodes
la série d'aval bien sûr qu'ils y ont
participé
oui ce que j'ai dit sur bfm sur x 7 à 8
ils ont fait un certain nombre
d'émissions france 2 etc
moi je ne critique pas le fait de deux
participé à la mort et à la chose
médiatique bien sûr et d'ailleurs ils
peuvent avoir des messages
ils peuvent aussi vouloir porter haut et
fort effectivement le souvenir d'alexia
je n'y vois aucun nombre âge
après ce qui m'interpelle ce serait un
peu comme nous de venir vous lire demain
dans la main on est passé à la télé hier
soir bon arrêtons l'hypocrisie et on
n'est pas obligé de passer à la télé il
y avait cent des gens qui refusent de
passer à la télé après on s'en prévaloir
comme d'un préjudice à part entière me
paraît quelque chose de
d'ailleurs la cour d'assises a rejeté
aujourd'hui elle a dit non non vous y
avaient participé
on ne conteste pas votre souffrance que
tout à fait lécher leur joie c'est comme
ça comme disais monsieur montée non
c'est pas le prix d'une vie qu'on a des
1000 faut savoir de combat que j'ai
l'impression en lisant ce que disait des
gens qui ne comprennent pas combien vaut
une vie non mais une vie n'est pas
quantifiable
c'est le prix de la douleur et des
nationaux le risque c'est que je voulais
dire que ça si ce courrier m un prix
est-ce qu'on n'a rien trouvé d'autre
voilà on traduit sans en argent ça ne
veut pas dire grand chose en réalité ça
me ça n'efface pas le chasser mais alors